Frances president and men while macaroni
is hosting the one planet summit today
in Paris focusing on climate change in
his first and only American network TV
interview macron talked to CBS Evening
News anchor Jeff Glor about his
relationship with President Trump
Jerusalem and climate change how often
do you speak to the president Ron Luke
as often as we need for instance the
rings of bass works really we had
probably three to four phone calls
together we have very fluent and open
discussion and you would characterize
that relationship is friendly yes very
direct you talked about Jerusalem yes
exactly before yes and he said what'd it
say that probably it will announce the
fact that he wanted to broken eyes
arisen as cattle of his role and you
told him what I told him I I thought it
was it was a mistake because we work and
we've worked all together on the
recognition of two states Israel and
Palestine with borders recognized by the
international community and that such a
unilateral decision is not compliant
with our international discussions and
international rules and will not
facilitate a peace process because
that's a unilateral decision and that's
pretty much in leading for the
Palestinian side was that a was that a
calm conversation was that a
confrontational conversation I think
it's always an open and direct
discussion you can agree to disagree
which is the case between us on some
some issues the United States will
withdraw from the Paris climate Accord I
was elected to represent the citizens of
Pittsburgh
not Paris President Trump says it's bad
news because it's bad for the American
workers bad for American people you I
did agree that what he means what he
wants to say expressing this this point
it's it's it's bad for American workers
it's just to see I will have to close
old plants coal activities and all the
stuff I mean it's true you will have to
switch from a model to another one
but I mean it's an understandable not to
deal with reality and what we know what
we have to protect these people
not jobs if you want to protect people
you retrain them you help them in order
to change their jobs to new ones much
more adapted and consistent with our
commitments and our collective interests
why do you think the president pulled
out of this first of all he was elected
by by you guys and as the president of
zia the American people and secondly
took a commitment during his campaign I
had a lot of discussion with him we have
a very good personal relationship and I
do believe it's important to have on
board the US government and all the
Americans but I do respect him and I do
respect his decision so I am NOT saying
he doesn't understand and doesn't share
the analysis but just it took a
political commitment how much has the
withdrawal affected your efforts I think
the withdraw to be totally fair with you
created a huge momentum to me to create
a counter momentum I launched the same
day of the announcement of the present
firm's decision to leave Paris agreement
I took an initiative called make up
Lynette great again it creates a huge
mobilization of a lot of countries
saying I do confirm and you had right
after the US announcement an
acceleration of the ratification process
in a lot of countries so just one letter
saying you say you're in better shape
now because of this withdrawal that the
president is your favorite mountain
because I think we have two phenomenon
so withdraw of the US which for me is a
mistake but it creates an impulse for a
lot of others to say okay we have to
react and do something because it's
impossible to leave the floor to a sort
of dismantling of the Paris agreement
second a deep wake-up call for the
private sectors and some of us to say
wow so we have to react otherwise
radically it will become a little bit
shaky just think one sec that if we
decide not to decide if we decide not to
move and not change our way to produce
to invest to behave
de facto we decide you decide to
condemned billions of people in the
coming decades that's a big decision and
we will I mean
office will be judged for that Jeff Glor
is full interview with the French
president will be airing today on our
streaming network cbsn